und jetzt wird's eklig denn wir müssen
über wurst reden deutschland hat wie sie
wissen seinen nächsten
gammelfleischskandal ja im kern
im kern geht es wie immer um tote tiere
die im discounter viel zu billig
vertickt werden um fehlende kontrollen
und mangelnde hygiene kurz gesagt um das
übliche diesmal halt in hessen
willkommen bei der wurst firma wilke
verschimmelte salami hängt neben fleisch
käse etwa vier wochen alt er soll mit
dem wasserschlauch abgespritzt danach
gebacken worden sein dann ging er
angeblich in den verkauf ja klar geht er
ihn verkauft die haben ja vorher extra
mit wasser abgespritzt jeder fällt mir
spontan eine idee für verschimmelten
fleischkäse einfach bisschen puderzucker
drüber paar rosinen rein fertig ist der
christstollen
natürlich muss man doch nicht
wegschmeißen firmen wie wilke müssen
immer billiger werden durch den
preisdruck der discounter
das ist das eigentliche problem und wenn
maschinen durchlaufen von morgens bis
abends werden sie eben nicht mehr
richtig gereinigt die folge diesmal kein
befall 34 erkrankte und drei tote es
schwer da noch die richtigen worte zu
finden
die todesopfer werden allerdings mit
keinem wort erwähnt die firma wilke
entschuldigt sich lediglich bei allen
kunden für die entstandenen
unannehmlichkeiten sollten ihnen durch
ihren tod unannehmlichkeiten entstanden
sein bedauern wir das anbei ein
gutschein über drei kilo fleisch käse
der bundesverband der
lebensmittelkontrolleure hat gerade erst
alarm geschlagen wegen personalmangels
sind im letzten jahr nur noch 42 prozent
der deutschen betriebe kontrolliert
worden
bei nicht genug leute da sind dann
brauchen wir auch nicht zu wundern wenn
alle möglichen sachen in meinem essen
landen gegenstände die
gesundheitsgefährdend sind
beispielsweise scharfe gegenstände in
die lebensmittel reingekommen sind
holzstücke glassplitter und in einem
fall sogar eine katzen kralle
jetzt neu maggi fix für chili con katze
so erst einmal dass einige von ihnen
wirklich entsetzt gucken jetzt ist der
fall wilke sicher ein extremer und nicht
repräsentativ aber das ändert nichts an
unseren systemischen problemen die wir
haben und die offenbar bleiben die
lebensmittelaufsicht wird bei uns
nämlich zum größten teil auf kommunaler
ebene zum beispiel bei den landkreisen
organisiert also von leuten die
natürlich auch ihre arbeitsplätze in der
region schützen wollen wenn wir das
alles so lassen wird sich nie was ändern
achten sie bitte darauf egal ob was
haben wir alles ehec oder pferde lasagne
jeder skandal läuft bei uns immer gleich
ab im grunde wie so ein ganz schlechtes
bauerntheater der deutsche lebensmittel
skandal eine farce in drei akten erster
akt wir finden unsere mutter was ekliges
sorgen durch bakterien oft erwischt
zweiter akt auftritt einer feschen
ministerin
die lava dann war es von besseren
kontrollen aber das sind natürlich die
länder zuständig man muss das unbedingt
aufklären aber nicht deutsches essen ist
sicher mahlzeit dritte akt alle essen
wieder wurst denn wegen der bakterien
unserem gehirn haben wir sowieso längst
vergessen was vor drei tagen in der
zeitung stand
[Musik]
dpa
ein theaterstück das in wechselndem
personal immer wieder neu aufhört und
der verbraucher hat sich leider
irgendwie dran gewöhnt dabei müssten wir
viel viel wütender sein
bis heute ist kein witz sagt uns niemand
wo die ganzen wilke produkte haben ende
gelandet sind einige offensichtlich in
krankenhäusern je schmier bruder hat in
26 ländern geliefert das kann keine sau
mehr nachvollziehen warum müssen die
lieferketten nicht lückenlos digital
erfasst werden man könnte die digital
erfassen und warum müssen beiträge über
solche skandale immer doofe wurst
wortspiele enthalten
so kommt die wahrheit weiterhin nur
scheibchenweise heraus erst heute wurde
bekannt dass wilke aufschnitt auch in
restaurants einige ikea filialen
angeboten wurde
oh gott jetzt reicht's bitte nicht der
großartige ein-euro-job von ikea
oder die leckeren coppola dann bin ich
wirklich sauer
was wollen sie einen noch nehmen dabei
waren wir deutschen noch immer so stolz
auf unsere tolle aufschnitt kultur ist
traurig ist traurig martin klempnow
leitet in köln nippes einem
fleischverarbeitenden betrieb der
ebenfalls in die ganze welt liefert wir
schon mal live rüber erklärt sie haben
da wie die firma wilke auch ein verkaufs
bistro merken sich schon irgendwas von
dem skandal skandal ein theater diese
bakterien sind doch nur gefährlich für
leute mit immunschwäche oder wirklich
sehr sehr alte leute die eh schon mit
einem fuß im na ja so schmieds er hat
also ich würde gleich hessen
die alte kannte jesus noch persönlich
der verbraucher muss endlich mal
realistisch werden sondern discounter
sagen wir mal aus spaß wurst wissen sie
eigentlich wie heutzutage noch wert ist
randvoll schätzt der materialpreis einer
solchen supermarkt wurst liegt höchstens
bei 30 cent pro kilo 30 cent pro kilo
was wird da wohl drin sein irgendwas was
man essen kann
euro wäre doch selber nicht hier
das rote übrigens hier in der wurst ist
keine paprika
ich möchte jetzt nicht ins detail gehen
aber viele von unseren osteuropäischen
mitarbeitern haben halt diesen
tuberkulose husten
aber ist auch ja und sagen sie mal vor
kontrollen haben sie gar keine angst der
marke also erst mal werden wir ja gar
nicht so oft vom staat kontrolliert
wegen personalmangel ja dafür gibt es
aber ein privates gütesiegel produkt hat
ifs siegel christmann wenn bei der
kontrolle weniger als 30 prozent
beanstandet wird ja da bekommt man dann
die urkunde
nur 29 prozent ekel anteil fast
genießbar nicht an riechen stall
runterschlucken die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass wirklich mal so ein kontrolleur
kommt die ist ja wahnsinnig gering
doch wenn einer kommt habe ich immer
noch dieses zeitfenster während der sich
in seinen caffier am zug rein früh
selbstverständlich stehen so ein
bisschen die sicht und lenkt ihn ab
ja und im hintergrund ragen meine
kollegin solange den gröbsten gammel weg
+10 rumänen bei uns neulich eine
maschine gefallen ist der welpe das ist
alles nicht schön aber was willst du
machen und die gute nachricht für mich
ist ja die deutschen kaufen meinen bilic
müll weiter jetzt mal ganz ehrlich was
ist denn die alternative was soll man
denn sonst fressen brokkoli um gottes
willen hat den körper lachen verführen
klickt hier für weitere heute schon
videos und clips verdachtsmomente
und klickt hier um den channel zu
abonnieren
[Musik]